now i've talked about right-sided abdominal pain
but i really haven't talked too much about pain on
the left side other than maybe one video and
it's really hard to find so this video is on
what happens if you have pain underneath the
rib cage on the left side what could that be
you have the liver here you have the pancreas here
so your liver is right here and your pancreas is
on the left side you have the gallbladder on
the right side and then you have all these
little tubes that help drain bile biles made in
your liver it drains through these little tubes
they're called ducts and most of it gets stored
in the gallbladder and it's concentrated by
five to seven times so then when you eat it gets
contracted and it squeezes out through here into
your small intestine well you also have a pancreas
that makes enzymes so the enzymes especially like
when you're dealing with fats the pancreas
releases the enzyme called lipase which helps
break down the fats but there's other enzymes as
well that are created by the pancreas and secreted
if you look at this area right here which is
kind of right in your below your stomach area
right here in the mid part you have a joining
of these bile ducts with the pancreatic ducts
so if by chance there's some type of gallstone
or obstruction in the in these pipes right
through in here or down here there's going to
be back pressure that goes into the pancreas
because these enzymes are now dissolving and
irritating itself so typically pancreatitis
comes from either way too much alcohol or
gall stones but up to 40 percent of the time
there's an idiopathic cause and that means
unknown cause but if you look up more data on this
there's an indication that you have
something called biliary sludge
it's kind of a pre-state or a pre-gall stone
where you're getting this thickened bile sludge
that is very hard to detect on either a cat scan
mri or even ultrasound because the crystals are
very very small and i'm going to put a link down
below if you want more information about this but
what happens if you have sludge that's kind
of clogging up these little pipes right here
and you have these little valves that might not
close properly we're not getting the drainage it
can back up and create this right here so this
sludge is concentrated cholesterol crystals
this does not come from having high cholesterol
or consuming too much dietary cholesterol it comes
from having a lack of bile because it is the bile
that is a key thing in your body to help regulate
this amount of concentrated cholesterol it's
the bile that helps keep the cholesterol thinned
and when you're lacking bile your risk for gall
stones increase you get more biliary sludge
and you start getting these crystals the solution
is not necessarily to go on a low cholesterol diet
it's to add more purified bile salts because
when you do that that will help to thin this
cholesterol bile material and allow drainage to
occur but if we go deeper and talk about what you
need to do to make sure that your body produces
more bile there's several things that you can do
cut your carbs down that's called healthy keto do
intermittent fasting cut down the amount of grains
that you consume because when you increase grains
you increase insulin and too much insulin can
deplete your bile reserve also too much estrogen
can do it too so if you're taking birth control
pills or even when a woman is pregnant and she has
a spike in estrogen that can mess with the bile
that's why women that are pregnant have a higher
risk of getting gallstones same thing with women
that are taking estrogen replacement therapy
vegetable oils are omega-6 highly inflammatory
this can also increase insulin and create insulin
resistance which then creates a problem with that
having too many nuts or nut butters can give you
too many omega-6 fatty acids and irritate this
area right here of course we talked about alcohol
you're going to have to cut down your alcohol to
no more than a six-pack on a weekend number seven
corn most corn is gmo that means it has glyphosate
which is very irritating to the inner lining of
your bile ducts right through in here also it's
a carbohydrate and then of course taking purified
bile salts this would be very very important take
one in them in the morning on an empty stomach
and take one in the evening on an empty stomach
and that can gradually help keep this flow opened
and keep it drained and reduce the inflammation
all right thanks for watching before you
go if you have a question about a product
or you're new to keto and you want to know
how to begin keto or you're on keto and you
need a debug because it's not going as smooth i
have a keto consultant standing by to help you
this is just for the people in the us hopefully in
the future we'll be able to answer everyone's call
but i put the number down below
so you can call and get some help